[Music]
so Hank this morning the first thing I
did was I got up and I went to look at
YouTube
and I was like that's weird I usually
see Hanks face on the front page of
YouTube it's a little oh my god we got
featured good morning Hank it's Thursday
July 25th Hank you're getting so many
comments that there's no way that you
can respond to all of them so I'm going
to do it for you until my four minute
deadline I'm going to read and answer as
many YouTube comments as I can Hank I
know you're wondering you're wondering
how am I gonna know John if it's you or
if it's a youtuber when you're reading
the answer is that when it's a youtuber
I'm not going to have green hair and
when it's me I am going to have green
hair lol what a sexy geek actually he's
a sexy nerd but that's a common mistake
it's Accio not Aki oh no its Akio not
Akio no it's not
dumbass it's oishi oh not Akio no it's
Akio no it's Akio no it's ash Kosh
B'gosh okay once and for all it's Osseo
stop bothering him you guys look like
The Proclaimers really did the
Proclaimers have green hair whoever made
this is a nerd yes that's the idea we're
nerds funny but could you look any
dorkier yes he could look dorky or he
could have spotty green hair why are
dogs scared of vacuums but not of peanut
butter faces that's a really good
question
maybe it's because vacuums are scary
whereas peanut butter faces are made of
Awesome Nigel is cool six five seven
rights
get a life nerd your screen name is
Nigel is cool six five seven did six
hundred and fifty six people before you
have the screen name Nigel is cool
furthermore to the best of my knowledge
no man in human history who is cool has
ever had the screen name blank is cool
ergo you are a nerdfighter sorry live
with it it's a good thing
what's a nerdfighter a nerdfighter is
like a regular person except instead of
being composed out of like tissues and
cells and organs they're made out of
awesome nerdfighters do stuff like hang
out the Brotherhood 2.0 form my pants
and embroider pillows Hey look at those
embroidered pillows they even put my
pants on them this was so jokes you have
real skills this isn't really response
to that comment but wouldn't it be great
if instead of saying cool we always said
jokes
yeah we just got featured on the front
YouTube it was pretty jokes man the
mountain goats are so jokes
hey is it hot outside no that's pretty
jokes um can you say obsession oh right
that's what you are
cough cough get a life when you say
cough cough get a life do you mean cough
get a life cough because get a life
isn't funny but you know what that's
funny
piss taker rights geek your screen name
is piss taker and you called Hank a geek
um I have a couple problems with the
screen name piss taker the big one is
this who isn't a piss taker like how
does being a piss taker set you apart
from the crowd
curse 45 rights got anything better to
do like make some money get a job Harry
Potter doesn't care about you cuz he's
not real Harry Potter isn't real oh no
wait wait what do you mean by real is
this videoblog real am i real if you can
see me and hear me but only through the
internet are you real if I can read your
comment but I don't know who you are or
what your name is or where you're from
or what you look like or how old you are
I know all of those things about Harry
Potter maybe Harry Potter's real and
you're not rusty just E 1 2 3 asks can I
put your face on the myspace I've heard
a lot about the myspace and I think it
would be fine if you put Hanks picture
on the myspace Wow he's 27
he looks like my little brother my
little brother's 10 he looks like my
little brother too and I think he's
awesome so that's all the questions I
can get through Hank congratulations I
don't even know how to celebrate I'm so
happy I think I'm gonna put silly string
in my hair and then do my happy dance
the NE is going to be really mad when
she gets home and sees the carpet happy
next time yes Hank I'll see you tomorrow